i have a lot of things to talk about but
the beginning of every interview i like
to throw some curveballs so um here we
go yeah
if someone has never seen
anything that you've done what's the
first thing you want them watching
ooh
that's a great question um
i don't know i think uh
i think shazam actually probably well i
don't know it's a toss-up between shazam
and chuck i think both of those projects
uh
represent kind of the things that i love
so much about i don't know entertainment
the the heart and the humor that's
involved in both of those projects um
very much in my wheelhouse very
enjoyable for me to to do um i would say
actually shazam
fury of the gods if i could point to
that i i'm super pumped about that uh
and i feel really good about it i think
i think you know obviously it's not out
for a little while but based on on our
shooting experience i think that might
end up being the thing that i would
point people to first but something in
there but or or
american underdog i think this is also
going to be a great opportunity for
people to
see a really great story and something
i'm very proud of the performance i put
into it and
kurt as a character is a really uh fun
one to play difficult in some ways but
very enjoyable oh i have so many
follow-ups to everything you've said
sure what when did you feel like you
made it as an actor that you could pay
rent by just acting
uh that was i did a show called less
than perfect it was a it was a
multi-camera sitcom on abc
uh
it's let's see we got picked up in
2002
so yeah in 2002 after about three years
of
grinding and you know getting pilots
that didn't get picked up and
the heartbreak that comes with that and
going back to busing tables and working
at a car wash and and then finally uh
less imperfect was picked up and that
was
the last time i had to have any kind of
a a regular j-o-b and i could just
depend on the acting to to pay the bills
which was a a glorious time
i know that you like playing video games
uh but
i know do you have what is the favorite
console what's the one that you get
trapped on the island and this is the
one that's coming with me um
i mean i i would say on on uh hours
logged i would say
uh the xbox um
i i probably have played my xbox more
than my playstation or my switch for
sure but i think they all have
great pros and cons i mean i i don't
know that i could i don't know that i
could live on that deserted island
without playing the last of us and i
could only play that on a playstation so
that's tough
uh but the switch is so great because
it's so portable and i can travel with
it and take it with me wherever i go and
i just wish you could get netflix and
stuff on the switch i really think they
need to up that game you know what i
mean
listen i love the switch but i also
think that the loading time i'm ready to
throw it through the roof like you know
it's it's it there's a lot of pros and a
lot of cons to the switch but more pros
than cons yeah i think so i think with
all of the systems to be honest they're
all so great nowadays
100 um i miss comic-con i know you must
miss comic-con do you have a favorite
comic-con that you attended like one
from all the years where you one just
like sticks out or are they all sort of
like a love of all of it
um
well i miss well there's many comic-cons
i'm assuming you're meaning con that's
in san diego yeah i'm talking about
santa yeah yeah um
i don't know man i mean honestly
i mean the first year that chuck got
picked up and i mean that was the first
year i had ever gone to comic con so
that was 2007
i think yeah 2007. uh that was
incredibly magical and memorable uh
ballroom 20 which is where we ended up
doing our
our panels for many years um
was packed to the gills mostly thanks
thanks to adam baldwin and his firefly
following and all that you know um but
people loved the pilot that we showed we
showed them the whole pilot and people
gave us a standing ovation i was like
this is insane this is so incredible
um
and then
i don't know man i mean you know doing
doing nerd hq there for many years like
there were those are probably definitely
some of my most memorable most
enjoyable memories just being able to
provide so much joy to
the talent and the fans and everybody in
between and
but as far as like as an actor just
going and promoting something
uh
you know coming back as shazam in what
was that 2018 i think it was before the
movie came out i think it was 2018 that
was
mind-blowing like to know that i started
that journey as this guy playing you
know uh um a disenfranchised nerd who
knows there's more to his life and but
he's stuck working at this you know big
box uh electronics store that that's
where i started my comic-con journey to
all the way to being a full-fledged
superhero in his own spandex uh was
insane it was just one of the coolest
like it felt very surreal and yet it was
very very real then i i i hope i get
more moments like that
yeah um the pandemic really sucks uh for
many reasons and one of which is losing
comic-con yeah yeah you know jumping
into why i actually get to talk to you
today um was this a role that you
talking about you know american underdog
uh was was this a role that you hunted
or did they hunt you
uh
more the latter actually yeah i mean
i was
always
a huge fan of kurt warner's and and this
whole story i mean i think anybody who
was aware of it at the time and you know
a lot of us were um
recognized just how special and magical
the whole thing was like for somebody to
you know go from stocking shelves in a
grocery store and not too long after
that get drafted as a much much older
rookie than would be normal and then to
be on the bench but then immediately get
called up in your second year and bring
your team all the way to the super bowl
and win it and you know get mvp and all
that jazz like you can't script that
stuff well you can we we scripted it and
made a movie out of it but uh but it's
it's incredible so i was always a fan of
the story
and uh to the extent that if they ever
made a movie of it it would be something
that i think would be really cool uh the
reality was i
i was unavailable for the movie until
the pandemic so i had i had shazam two
and some other projects that were all
lined up and they because i was
unavailable were moving forward the
irwin brothers had always kind of had me
in mind i think i myself and a you know
few other people were kind of some of
their top choices but i was i was
unavailable
and then all of a sudden you know uh
this crazy stuff starts going down in
the world all of my projects at that
moment all got pushed or put on hold or
whatever it was and uh as the same thing
happened with american underdog but
because of its
production size and because lionsgate
was open to trying making it happen and
the irwin brothers were open to trying
making it happen in the pandemic and we
could we could figure it out you know it
was a much more manageable production
than let's say shazam fury the gods
that's a much larger thing to try and
coordinate in the middle of the pandemic
but um
we were they were able to spin up
american underdog and i was already
friends with the irwin boys we were
collaborating on another project and
they go listen
we really think that you're our kurt
warner you've been you know our top
choice and one of our top choices for a
long time you weren't available now you
are would you be open to this and uh so
that's that's kind of how it came to be
and
i thought you know uh
i read the script the script is
fantastic uh i i laughed i cried i was
very moved by you know so much of the
story that i didn't even know before you
know everybody knows the football side
of kurt's story but very few people know
the
the the the uh the journey that he and
brenda and their kids went through the
struggles that they went through that i
think are incredibly relatable to you
know anyone who's gone through any kind
of struggle you recognize that you know
life is not easy and particularly for
them in iowa at that time in their lives
they were you know pinching pennies and
struggling just to get by
but never letting go of the dream never
letting go of
this um
[Music]
this this dream this vision that kurt
really believed that he had since he was
a kid and um so all of it just felt very
i don't know it felt very faded it felt
like you know not not to say that the
pandemic was faded and then therefore i
was fated to be in this movie but i do
think that god does some pretty cool
stuff making lemons are making you know
lemonades out of making lemonade out of
lemons and the pandemic was a hell of a
lot of lemons for a lot of people and i
felt like this was some really tasty
lemonade that i got out of it
what would you rather spend the day
doing uh wearing the nfl uniform or the
shazam suit
[Laughter]
probably the nfl uniform just because uh
at least i could i could drop a deuce if
i needed to you know you got to take the
whole darn shazam suit off if you if you
want to go number two which is not very
convenient let me tell you you got to be
very careful about your diet you know
like no taco bell no not a lot of chili
you never know what's going to be just
running through you and you're like oh
oh oh unzip me unzip me i gotta go
it's funny you say that i just did a set
visit in ireland and i was thinking we
were on location away from a lot of
things and i started thinking about i
really need to be thinking about what
i'm about to eat and drink because
you're in the middle of nowhere you know
that's a whole i don't mean to put
myself in that but no no it's okay i
it's relatable i totally understand yeah
it's it's crazy so um one of the things
the nfl is the most popular
sport in america but it's amazing to me
that so few movies get made or even tv
shows um
did that even enter your brain at all
like this is a completely random thing
but it you would think more stories
would be told about the nfl but they're
few and far between yeah i mean i i
think that there's a couple of factors
that are probably and i'm not the
authority on this but i just in kind of
you know top of my head i would say that
you know one
um american sports
uh
are obviously very popular in the united
states i think sometimes studios are
wondering well will this translate
internationally uh american football i
think though it is probably yeah the
most famous or you know most successful
american pastime
translates less internationally than
baseball or basketball both of those
have a more international presence so if
you're going to make a story about a
professional sport those might translate
a little bit more internationally
another reason i think that's probably
behind that is the nfl has always been
very from my knowledge they've always
been very protective of their brand to
the extent that they don't want like for
example any given sunday which i thought
was a really fun movie right but that
movie doesn't necessarily
paint professional football in all of
the the brightest light there's a lot of
like dark side or other you know other
other angles to what that story was well
the nfl wasn't going to have that they
were like listen we don't we don't want
to do that whereas like major league
baseball you could go make a major
league which was about real you know
major league baseball teams and like all
of the crap and all of the all of the
you know crazy things that go on it
doesn't paint everybody exactly in a
great light but the mlb was like go for
it you know what that's that's a fun
story that's a funny story and it didn't
i think end up doing any damage at all
to the reputation of major league
baseball and if anything people loved
that movie and it got them a little more
interested in baseball when they watched
it so i think there's a couple different
factors like that you know
these are all excellent excellent points
what surprised you the most about
sitting down with kurt and brenda uh
that perhaps you just you know that
really surprised you about talking with
them and getting ready for the movie
were there's certain things that you're
like you know what i mean like yeah i
think
interesting
yeah yeah you know i got you i mean
i i would say that learning about their
their story first and foremost i mean
you know reading this script and
learning all these things that i
was not aware of that again most people
i don't think are aware of
um that was fascinating uh and then you
know i only got to sit down with them
for a couple of days before we started
shooting because the pandemic obviously
was making travel and hanging out with
people all very uh you know crazy
unlimited um
[Music]
but uh but then they
they then were on set with us a lot i
mean maybe even more than half the time
they were there on set and you know
mostly just observing you know
occasionally would have a a note or a
thought here and there
um
you know maybe like this moment kind of
happened more like this or this is where
they were more emotionally and i would
try to you know look if you got that
well i would go to that well as much as
i could like yo does that like when you
come on onto the field i remember asking
i was like you know which which way did
you you know unbuckle or unclip your
your your chin your chin strap or like
what do you do you know like this is he
was you know this was kind of his move
he would come out and kind of you know
do two fingers to this guy and you know
it's all those things that sometimes
even when you're watching tape or
whatever you don't necessarily know that
these are the habits or these these are
like the little minutiae things um
but with brenda and kurt
to be honest you know the thing that i
always knew or saw in all the press
coverage or you know the stories told
about them was that they were they were
a really solid unit like they were a
couple that really loved each other
really got along really cared about each
other really supported each other and uh
so to see all that manifest in real life
in very very very real ways like even to
this day they're they are incredible
they're an inspiring couple genuinely
the way they love each other the way
they love their kids the way they
parents the way they you know co-exist
all these years later it's it's it's
it's relationship goals and so
i was not surprised in that i had heard
that or seen that but i was pleasantly
surprised to find out that that was the
truth
it was tougher the barn dance or filming
the football scenes
oh filming the football scenes for sure
i'm a bit of a dancer so um so the barn
dance wasn't too it wasn't too bad uh i
learned that pretty quick but no man
they the football stuff you know i was
only given about a month and a half to
try and um
figure out how to be a hall of fame
you know a super bowl winning
quarterback and uh i wish i had more
time again pandemic you know we had
limited limited time and resources i had
a great football coach clint dolizel
um
and he really i mean you know talk about
a crash course and becoming a
quarterback like we we did it um but you
know you want more time you want you
want to uh also you know some of the
hits in the movie that kurt takes that
was me i had doubles that took some of
the crazier hits but there were a lot of
hits that you know i genuinely took and
um
and that's not nearly as enjoyable as
you know wearing cowboy boots and
dancing around and you know
but it was also kind of fun i i enjoyed
the simulation i mean granted a much
slower
scale simulation of you know being an
nfl quarterback he was getting hard far
he was getting hit far harder than i
ever was when we were making the movie
but uh
yeah it was uh it definitely left some
marks some bruises of bumps and bruises
yeah
uh yeah at least you're like six two or
you're tall you have some weight if i
tried to do anything that you did i
would literally be killed i would you
know i mean
it's possible but we would also have
medics on on you know standing by so
wouldn't
wouldn't help listen before i ran out of
time with you uh as you know i am kind
of a fan of shazam
kind of uh it was kind of good i'm just
gonna i want to lower the ego yeah sure
of course
of course um but seriously though for
fans that love the first one like me
what can you tease about the sequel
i mean
yeah so i mean i i you know how i feel
about spoilers so i or how we all should
feel about spoilers which is we don't
say them um
but i will say that
i i genuinely and this is not just lip
service i i really do think that we
you know i'm very proud of the first one
i think we made a really really good
movie uh i think the second one is
better i think that we uh we had more
time we had more budget uh everyone
you know we had essentially the entire
cast returning um
and uh
we all knew our characters a little bit
more we could we could you know kind of
sit into them a little bit more
um
uh um henry gaiden who wrote the first
script wrote the second and he did a
fantastic job doing so um
yeah i don't know man like everything
just clicked even a little bit more and
a little bit more and and also the kids
have grown up a little bit more so even
the sensibilities of them becomes even
slightly bit
more mature which brings it closer to my
adult mind which means uh there or other
people's adult minds so there's even
more you know uh connection there i
think or whatever but um
the action's great the comedy's great
the relationships are great the bad guys
helen mirren and lucy liu are fantastic
like
i'm i'm very proud of it i hope i want
it to come out sooner than june of 2023
that's the thing that makes me crazy
because i was looking at the release
date i'm like oh it comes out next
summer and i'm like are you effing
kidding me it's 20 23. two summers yeah
yeah i'm not down with this well listen
i mean look
fortunately we're
we are amongst a a huge
group of very cool characters and
actors that play those characters that
they're already
more established in a lot of ways
because of the dc movies that
pre-existed before we came in so we're
you know we're kind of like that we're a
little bit of a jv coming into the to
the varsity squad and uh you know
there's a lot of titles that need to be
that need to come out to the world and
so if that's where we fall in the queue
because i get it studios have to be you
know you have to make a concerted effort
about
uh not cannibalizing your own time you
know uh titles like you you can't
release them too close to each other
otherwise you might cannibalize each
other plus you have to take into
consideration all the other studios
releases and all that stuff so that's
where it is but but you never know maybe
it'll come out sooner
here's here's here's hoping and praying
i hope listen summer summer 2023 means
they're very confident in the movie it's
just that's the time that they figured
out so i of course have to ask you um
have you been in in any contact with
dwayne and like bad-mouthing each other
about who's actually gonna win when you
two fight no no no no i mean there's
been there's been some funny little
things back and forth like in character
on twitter or something like that so
somebody had asked him like you know
what what is how how could shazam
possibly stand up to black adam and to
which he replied he doesn't but you know
but then he he labels it black out as if
black adam is saying that so i don't
know i don't know dwayne i i have no
communication with them but you know i
i know that we're all going to be a part
of you know we're all a part of the big
same big happy dc family and i look
forward to whatever cocktail parties
we're all at together yeah i i can't
wait to see the two of you in the film
together as your characters i gotta stop
there and i'm just gonna say seriously
congrats on american underdog i thought
you did such a great job and wish you
nothing but the best thanks brother good
to see you